[Musik]
da ich mich setzen
ich glaube ja deutschland hat viel mehr
geld als die meisten deutschen wissen
wirklich also obwohl man muss eigentlich
sagen deutschland ist jetzt kein reiches
land ich würde sagen deutschland ist ein
land der reichen wissen sie wie viele
millionäre ist in deutschland geht
1,4 millionen ich glaube es gibt in
deutschland weniger menschen die wissen
wie viele millionäre es geht als
millionäre ziemlich gefragt was wäre ein
gutes bild um so die ganzen
einkommensverhältnisse mal abzubilden
ich glaube deutschland ist wieder okay
ist vier-sterne-hotel so ein bisschen
angestaubt seit den neunzigern nichts
mehr gemacht aber ganz okay so das hat
so 50 stockwerke sagen wir mal und die
stockwerke sind geordnet nach einkommen
ja also wenn du niedriges einkommen hass
hass ein unteres stockwerk wenn ein
hohes hafen höher ist so also im
fünfzigsten stockwerk sitzen die leute
sind richtig reich namens bieten so und
du darfst auch mal die anderen
stockwerken gruppen aber immer nur fünf
stockwerke nach oben und fünf stockwerke
nach unten
ich glaube so ist deutschland irgendwie
deshalb können sich reiche nicht
vorstellen die es angeht und aber nicht
wie viel reichtum es gibt immer nur so
ungefähr
ich spiele jetzt sind man das spiel
catching wie geht gute frage ich nehme
einmal magazin
der retter ist durch und das frage ich
mich immer ist die person die ich gerade
sehr vielleicht millionär oder nicht und
immer wenn ich davon ausgehen die person
ist wahrscheinlich millionär sagt singh
und trinken likör habe ich neulich mit
dem bahn magazin gemacht ich bin nur bis
seite 15 gekommen hätten wir sonst
diesen magen auspumpen müssen die hälfte
einfach nur millionäre sind dieser
vorkommen in dem magazin
ja und das ist aber einem gar nicht so
bewusst wenn man sich die frage gar
nicht stellt beide nicht sex ist die
leute reich sind bereiche reden über die
welt aber die die probleme sehen wir ja
nicht in ungerechte vermögensverteilung
noch einmal zurück zum hotel deutschland
die obersten stockwerke zahl natürlich
spitzensteuersatz sind dreieinhalb
millionen menschen in deutschland
und da denkt man sich ja krass die
zahlen den höchsten steuersatz müssen
sehr reich sein stimmt aber nicht
2009/10 verdienen menschen im
durchschnitt 3 1994 euro der
spitzensteuersatz jeder war schon bei
4.700 euro los das heißt die hälfte der
leute die den spitzensteuersatz zahlen
nur etwa 50 prozent mehr vom
durchschnittseinkommen also ich meine
viele die den spitzensteuersatz zahlen
sind jetzt nicht superreich also im
sinne von ich ich vermisse meinen polo
spielen reicht er so reich im sinne von
jo heute nehme ich mal den döner teller
spezial auch extra gucke ich nicht auf
den preis
jetzt kommt ein satz den man sich nicht
vorstellen kann
45 menschen besitzen in deutschland so
viel wie die erste hälfte der
bevölkerung also ist nicht 45.000 also
45 menschen an genauso viel wie 40
millionen menschen
und ich habe gedacht zu krass 540
menschen das sind ja eigentlich so viele
wie im reisebus passen
stellen wir uns mal vor sie fahren jetzt
von berlin nach köln im reisebus
sie wollen die kerze anzünden im dom er
für alle die nicht milliardäre sind
könnte ja sein und sagen wir mal die
legen ihr vermögen an und kriegen so 2
prozent im jahr dafür nicht viel aber
gehen wir noch raus ist super wenig aber
gehen wir davon aus so eine acht stunden
fahren dann verdienen die während der
fahrt 4 millionen euro habe ich
ausgerechnet ich weiß es klingt wie eine
komische mattes textaufgabe ich habe ja
alles auch sein vier millionen euro
kriegen
das heißt wenn ihr im stau stehen kann
die das geld von denen die im stau
stehen aus dem fenster werfen werden
deren jahresgehälter aus dem fenster
werfen und sagen tanz für uns und wenn
sie ankommen in köln haben sie genauso
viel geld wie vorher so reich und da
nehme ich mich jetzt mal ein bisschen
aus dem fenster
ich finde es ungerecht vor allem weil
die 45 leute keine angst haben müssen
dass sie erwischt werden wenn die
steuern hinterziehen zum beispiel das
ist auch bewiesen
je mehr geld du hast desto weniger prüft
das finanzamt ob du vielleicht bescheißt
also die regel zum zusammenfassung
er hat die regel in deutschland ist alle
zahl steuern und je mehr du verdienst
desto mehr muss zuzahlen
es sei denn du wirst superreich das
heißt der deutsche staat schützt reiche
vor steuern
na klar ich könnte auch sagen reiche
können werden arme nicht mehr
ich wünsche mir für die über 700
mitglieder im bundestag zufall berater
innen ja gerufen dann jeden tag an und
fragen was haben sie heute dafür getan
dass alle ihre steuern zahlen und wenn
sie sagen nichts
zieht man von denen ein hartz4 regelsatz
ein
ich glaube wenn man das macht so am
montag 1 führt dann würde man am freitag
merken war haben wir auf einmal viel
geld übrig
wow
es prickelt die reichen aus dem bus
weißt du was sie in der zeit verdienen
die du als geringverdiener brauchst um
den kanal zu abonnieren willst du gar
nicht wissen aber kleiner tipp je
schneller du klickst desto weniger ist
es deswegen bachmann
danke
ich hätte noch mehr also wer gut wenn
ihr jetzt